uh Chairman's notices
oh I'm councilor Michael helm by the way
um Chairman's notices
this meeting has been recorded
we'll be recorded and published on the
council's website any part of the
meeting held in Open Session fire in the
event of a fire the siren will sound
sound please use the far exit marks with
the green Running Man the far assembly
point is outside the main entrance of
the council buildings please gather
there and wait further instructions
health and safety Please be aware of
different levels in the council chamber
meeting is being held to the council
chamber as being monitored and recorded
by CCTV
if you want the lift it doesn't work
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded during each item please put
your hand up and indicate if you wish to
speak
could you also say your name at the time
for the benefit of YouTube
I will then invite you at the
appropriate time please note the YouTube
live stream sound recording is dependent
on the correct use of the microphone so
make sure you switch your microphone and
speak into it and turn it off when
finished please reference the page and
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
right
apologies for absence Tara
and Richard Holmes as well
she's not very well
uh minutes of the last meeting held on
the 10th of March on pages five to ten
uh uh are approved at your next great I
so move do I have a sector for this
right got that
any member wish to speak or raise any
matter of accuracy they need to indicate
if they wish to speak
cool this is good
Public's participation we have none I
don't believe Sarah is that right
yeah I got that next the close of it
disclosure of Interest please any
disclosure interests
no right probably they'll come on
we have now molden District Community
safety partnership update Pages 11 to
36.
and who's going to present that
Spence will present that thank you chair
um for the benefit of those uh joining
on the YouTube link my name's uh Spencer
Clark and I'm the community safety
manager for Malden District Council
um members would have had a report in
advance
um to read and what I'm going to try not
to do is uh Sergeant Matt dalby's got a
presentation which follows this so I'll
try not to duplicate anything
um I have uh put a few slides up for the
benefits of members just to go through
some of the statutory process we have as
a community safety partnership and uh
just to explain a few of the pieces of
good practice we've been doing in the
last year and highlighting a little bit
on Horizon scanning on where we think
crime could be going and what sort of uh
new
um Powers will be coming in in the next
year or so
um so on on page
um 11 uh of the report this just goes
through the statutory duties and Tara if
you could go on to the first slide
that'd be useful please
um so this is just really to flag up
what a the statutory duties of a
community 30 partnership is
um so when I say a community safety
partnership it's not just modern
District Council and Essex police it's
also the other agencies such as the fire
service such as the probation service
health services and uh
I think that's what the agency said so
so it's all of the agencies all work
together and from the partnership so the
piece of legislation we work to is the
climate disorder act 1998 and by all of
those agencies working together we have
what's called a responsible authorities
group
um so uh I chair the current modern
District Council responsible authorities
group and we get good attendance from
all statutory Partners at the moment I'm
pleased to say and when I did miss out
was Essex County Council sorry about
that but that all of the partners are
around the table which is really good
together with elected members uh one of
which is here tonight in Council hebner
so um that's a um that's what we do as a
group
um the other statutory piece of work we
do each year is what's called a
strategic assessment that starts
roundabout now so we work on data from
the 1st of October to the 30th of
September so we've just got into October
so we work on that piece of data from
last year and we gather evidence from
all of the data from police fire road
traffic collisions Etc and that enables
us to uh look at what we're going to be
focusing on for the following year we
also work on Public Health Data so
things like Hospital admissions Etc but
more importantly for somebody like
Malden we also take into account public
perceptions
so we can work on perception data so one
of the things that regularly comes up
when we ask members the public
what do you want to see in Malden it's
around Road Safety any responsible
driving that always comes up as normally
the number one concern for Malden
so once we've completed this strategic
assessment we then agree that priorities
when I say we the responsible Authority
group agrees at priorities so we're in a
position where next week we'll receive
our crime risk Matrix and we'll sit down
as a partnership probably with my
colleagues next to me here and we'll
score the Matrix and then the police
will then do a little bit of analytical
work on our four key priorities so
they'll do like a deep dive so if we're
talking about drugs and gangs they'll do
that piece of work there to enable us to
focus on it better
once we've agreed those priorities which
is usually around March time
um we'll then have an action plan for
delivery and it enables us to monitor
progress and also the financial spend on
that particular one if you recall a
couple of years ago through all
different governance we had some
recommendations from that so we read
Amber green rate that action plan now
for the partners to look at each time
the other other piece of statutory work
we do is present to overview and
scrutiny twice a year which is one of
which I'm doing tonight
thank you uh Tyler we can move on to the
next one so these are our current
priorities for Malden
and uh
I wouldn't expect them to change
dramatically uh for next year so that
all things you'll be familiar with so
the sort of things we've been doing is
tackling crime and reducing reoffending
one of the things we did at this year
was around High armor fences
and the second one is around driving
down anti-social Behavior
a third around identifying and
supporting vulnerable people so one of
the things we added this year is around
violence against women and girls and I'm
working on a strategic group uh County
group about uh having uh violence
against women and girls strategy across
Essex
um also social isolation and I'll go on
a little bit about that later on why we
need to flag that
the other two are around rural crime and
as I said before around promoting uh
road safety and uh challenging
irresponsible driving
so for the next slide please Tara
um what I thought I'd do is I'd do a
little bit of a focus on what we do well
I'm just picking out a few things from
the report rather than going through in
detail so I'm not planning to go say
anything about crime statistics because
I'm going to leave that to the police
one I've asked statutory duties is
around uh preventing violent extremism
um so I chair the Essex prevent delivery
group across Essex and uh only this
afternoon I had the local contest board
uh where I sit down mainly with members
of Essex police to discuss what's going
on around the protect and prevent duties
so what have we've been doing this year
so I took this role on just over a year
ago and as you can well imagine in the
last year around prevent it's been a
little bit Lively there's been a lot
going on so one of the first things we
have undertook on behalf of Essex was a
local benchmarking exercise where we
gathered together what's going on across
the whole of Essex
I'm pleased to say the home office uh
scored us as free you can get one two
three four and five
free is a pretty good score it's Duty
met so for an area such as vessax which
isn't a funded area so we're not a
London borough or a metropolitan City we
don't get any funding towards prevent we
got a score of three
um the only thing which really
stops is getting more was there's a few
outstanding things we need to do one of
those is what we call a situational risk
assessment which uh looks at what all
the risks are around prevent and what's
being done I've actually completed that
now and a draft have been sent to the
home office and they're quite happy with
that we're just waiting for some uh
input from some of the other districts
across Essex so that's that's been
complete so I'd like to think that next
year when we go through the benchmarking
exercise we'll edge up to a four which
will be really good for an unfunded area
one of the other things we've done this
year and some of the members would have
attended this on the hottest day of the
year
um uh I've done some work with elected
members around prevent some of you may
have attended it I think we had 16 of
the Malden members attend that uh and
we've done a work to round the home
office uh
guidebook for elected members so that it
gave members more of a awareness around
prevent and I'll use that as an
opportunity to do some general
safeguarding training as well
so that that sort of uh presentation
which we've done to members has uh been
circulated to a number of the other
districts in Essex because they want to
follow suit on that
um in terms of what we've been doing I
mean when I took on the chair of this
group
um I'm not one for sitting in lengthy
meetings so I I cut them down a bit to
90 minutes and now what we do is a
90-minute meeting followed by an hour of
a learning exercise so the first
exercise which we've done there was
around uh exploring anti-minority
narratives we've heard Dr Gareth Harris
and the most recent one which I done in
September was with Dr Simon Masood who's
a expert on neurodiversity and how uh
people who have
a new route over us
um
camality uh have a susceptible to
radicalization and it's really
interesting to explore that and when we
actually put it out to a wider wider
groups we had 96 people attend that
training exercise which is really good
um just another thing about that is
around uh prevent
[Music]
um
links with hate crime if you look at
hate crime stats you look at prevent
referrals there's a clear link between
that and it's important that what we do
is respond to local concerns and more
importantly local concerns and Community
tensions again go together hate crime
Community tensions so that's that's
that's a piece of work we've been doing
well you might think it might not ever
happen in Malden only last month we had
patriotic alternative leaflet in in a
molden so patriotic alternative who have
been very very active in Essex in the
last year or so so it is going on and
it's important that if you do get
anything around that you report it so
we've got the intelligence as to where
it's happening so that was just a little
bit about prevent uh Tara if you could
go on to the next slide I've uh rather
than going through the report word for
word I've done a little bit on Horizon
scanning and what's going to be
happening over the next year
so one of the new duties which comes in
will be the serious violence Duty
um we don't quite know what that's going
to look like yet we do know that every
District in Essex will have to pay
attention to this and have to do work
around it
um one of the other areas I work in is
around violence and vulnerability and
I've uh sit on the balance and
vulnerability operations group and the
violence and vulnerability group has
decided that they'll do this piece of
work for Essex
so they'll do all the data management
around the serious violence Duty and we
expect that to come in early next year
so that's something perhaps at the March
meeting uh when we meet again I'll be
able to tell you in a bit more detail
about what we'll be doing around serious
violence
a lot of it is around data sharing which
we do already the sheer fact that we
work alongside the police and we share
that data really well you know so I I
think it's a lot of the stuff we already
do I think this Duty has been brought in
for agencies that don't share data so
we're interested to see around that the
other thing which uh may come in next
year I think uh it's a
it's been going on a well of the protect
Duty now so the protect Duty comes out
of the uh after the tragic Manchester
Bonnet bombing which is now four years
ago uh the actual consultation on
protect was done last July
um so um and the home of his published
the findings of the protect Duty uh in
January things really haven't moved on a
lot since then so I don't I can't put my
hand on my heart and say that protect
Duty will be coming in next year
um what will happen is that they'll be
looking at the the publicly accessible
locations and each district will have a
duty around that so say for example if
we looked at a publicly accessible
location for Malden I think Malden
Promenade would feature very high and
where it's a district council would have
uh uh have to pay duty to that around
having competent persons around managing
those areas so when I say competent
persons people who are adequately
trained around counterterrorism
so that's something which will come in
next year the pals but the protect Duty
um I think uh what's been happening with
the government in the last year it's
probably not high on their agenda at the
moment
another thing which is uh lapsed a bit
is the home office review of community
safety Partnerships
so um the home office are working with
the police and crime Commissioners and
they'll be reviewing
um
how Community safety Partnerships work
again this is a piece of work which was
meant to be completed it was meant to be
like a light touch three-month review
again that's been stalled and I just can
imagine it's because of what's been
happening happening in the government
over the last year or so
um we we in Essex are already in a good
position we've already done a lot of
meetings I've attended LGA meetings and
given feedback around what we think
should be happening
um
and uh I I'd like to think Essex is in a
relatively good place and we've been
working the working very closely with
the commissioner's office around that so
uh again hopefully in March I'll be able
to feedback a bit more about what what
is expected and what the anticipation
will be for Community safety
Partnerships going forward
so what else is going to impact on crime
um I think every day we hear about the
the cost of living crisis and uh things
like the cost of food only only
yesterday or I was reviewing some of the
uh data around field poverty so when you
think about field poverty you might
think about areas of deprivation but you
can also think about asset rich areas so
somewhere like tillingham could be what
we call an asset Rich area where people
might be living in their own homes but
might not they might be retired and not
have uh the funding available to heat
their homes going forward so I think we
need to look very carefully about that I
know that's not direct link to Crime but
where it could have a link is around
things like fire safety and we're in a
position in Malden where in the last 12
months we've had free fatal fires now
normally there's three fatal fires a
year in Essex
and all of those fires have been very
very similar in the victim being a lone
person who has been socially isolated
and had a clutter stroke accordion
Tendencies so a piece of work we're
doing with the fire service
is uh doing a little bit of work around
data about where we're trying to predict
what areas we can Target with what we
call Safe well and secure visits and
it's getting back to old-fashioned door
knocking you know because most of these
victims were probably known to the
community but not necessarily known to
services so I think that's a pretty
important piece of work going forward
finally I I know we all speak about the
pandemic being over and everything but
in terms of the impact going forward
it's still massive one of the groups I
Vice chair is Majestics children's
partnership board and seeing the spike
in mental health amounts young people
this year is going through the roof so
it's somewhere we really need to look at
as I said before social isolation and
impact that can have I just mentioned
those Three Fires we had but also an
increase in vulnerability people were
you know it still has that impact even
two or three years down the line
thank you Tara if we can just move on to
the next slide
so I said I'd flag up some some of the
good practice which we do uh at Malden
um and again I I hope I'm not
duplicating anything which uh
um so Sergeant Toby or chief acting
Chief Inspector Kelly fursten's going to
say so I will
um so I had a joint working Arrangements
I mean the Hub Arrangements work really
well
um one thing which has really worked
well for molding is to try service role
so many of you were bumped into Les
Davis I think in a joint strategic
commandment a strategic coordination
meeting I refer to him as the the savior
of the danger so the work that Liz has
been doing has been fantastic
um not just
giving advice about fires but whenever
we're doing patrols he's always there he
knows the community so well people like
speaking to the fire service they like
talking to us do them but they're much
more approachable to fire service
so so you know that that's a really good
piece of work and I'm pleased to hear
that they're actually extending that
role to uttlesford District next I think
I believe so it's a role that works
really well in rural areas so that's
really good and the close working
relationship we have with the
Essex police rural engagement team
um around things like hair coursing you
know they've been doing so much work
around that the reductions in hair
coursing
the reductions in unauthorized
encampments in the last year is
fantastic both for over around 50 aren't
they which is really good the way uh
we've been working alongside that
other areas we've done quite a lot of uh
this year's around Community engagement
uh it's been nice to get outside again
and speak to people you know we've had
two years of pandemics so there's been
lots of events and we're trying to get
to most areas we've been to from Park
twice we've been to Riverside Park in
Burnham we've been to tolsbury we're at
heybridge next week on Wednesday of next
week so we're trying to get out into
those areas
um another good piece of work was a
couple of months ago we had our street
week for Malden
um councilor hebner myself spent the
morning on Malden High Street talking to
members of the public and uh and
drinking coffee and you know and
generally having a good chat with people
and it really worked quite nicely we we
rocked up outside the bus stop and
everyone was pleased to see us so doing
that General uh engagement was good but
also the patrols and I'm not going to
say any more about that because I know
that my colleague is going to pick up on
the things like the social media and the
just dispatch
education and awareness is a really
important part of community safety
you would call last year crucial crew
had to go virtual because the pandemic
this year we were back face to face so
we've done a bit of a mixture of
face-to-face delivery and virtual
delivery
I went to the first set at Malden
football club and the young people were
so much engaged in the professional
drama because it was face to face you
know and it's a good hour and a half
exploring things around vulnerability
after that and I was really pleased the
way that went and for those schools that
couldn't get out to those areas we still
delivered the virtual delivery for them
because as we know the prices of coaches
these days is quite High
so that that worked really well we we've
already planned on that again for next
year I think we've already booked
Melbourne football stadium uh for for
one of the events next year
and uh also when I spoke about being
responsive
um we had some issues around hate crime
in Burnham earlier this year so the same
company who uh uh delivered the
professional drama for crucial crew went
into a school and delivered the same
professional drama around hate crime so
providing some hate crime awareness for
young people so being responsive there
the other types of things we've offered
are things like safer places have been
asked to do healthy relationship
sessions in the schools
um reach every generation of us had been
do work around exploitation we've done
the general safeguarding awareness
training the j9 training which is around
domestic abuse we've got another
Community session coming up
um
on the 24th of November which has been
advertised so if anyone wants to join
that they're more than welcome to and
finally one of our most recent events
was the older persons event at moldham
Stadium where we had over 80 uh over 65
to turn up and again a very successful
event and uh we've got we've got
practitioners lining up to do next year
already I think we've got a knitting a
knitting a knitting group we want to
attend the next one but it's great it's
great to see people chatting to people
um you know and it's all about reducing
social isolation and making people uh
more confident and they can learn lots
of things about scams Etc on things like
that
um finally on this slide
um what we're trying to do more of is
effective use of Technology
mold and District uh I think we're the
first and only District to introduce
truecam
um which is uh added added enforcement
on our roads
um in the last in the last couple of
years so that's that's this year and
2021 which uh was a bit of a slightly
more difficult year because it was a bit
stop start and go because of the
pandemic we've done five short of 6 000
uh effective stops and reports so those
six thousand stops in those space of
time people either go for driver
training or get a prosecution
so that's much over and above what the
police can actually deliver in those
areas really important part of the work
we do so on average we do about 40 hours
a month about 19 different sites and
parishes so that's a really important
piece of work as you know a couple of
years ago we upgraded the CCTV system to
a high definition system we get some
good results from that last week
about this time at four o'clock we had
an arrest for somebody with a bloated
article on the High Street so you know
things like that do happen in Malden but
it is effective on the way we work it
another thing we're introducing very
very soon when I say very very soon I've
got the base station here with me
tonight because I've just picked it up
off the desk there's a new radio system
New Wave radio system for Malden
District as you probably know uh Malden
doesn't lie very well in terms of radio
connectivity because the morality of it
this new wave radio system works on
mobile phone data so it will hop to
whatever mobile phone data network is
available so our offices whenever
wherever they're going to be in the
district will be able to speak direct
with each other and back to the CCTV
control room in Chelmsford as well so
that's something that's being introduced
that's what I said about being data
driven
um what one area of work which uh we're
getting so much better data around is
the fire service the fire data we're
getting things like cluster one two and
three fires and it enables us to focus
our activity much better
okay
um I think this is the final slide Tower
there you go there is I've probably got
a picture on it Everyone likes a picture
so this was uh last week
um last week was hate crime awareness
week so on Wednesday we spent the
morning when I say we that's me taking a
picture honestly
um so I was there got less uh on the on
the far side there you've got Les Davis
who's that trying service pilot
got Scott Smith who's there Community
safety engagement officer tool um
up until last Friday
and then the rosie who's hiding behind
the person there who's the Malden
Community safety engagement officer and
that's again we we chose the same
location as we did for Street weeks
because so much football there
buses stop there people get off the
buses and they want to have a chat with
you
um next step is we're going to be doing
some work in the schools a bit further
uh going into the schools and doing some
more education but that's that's uh I've
tried to make that a little bit more
interactive by rather than just going
through the report
um because members had an opportunity to
read that in advance so uh um
I'll I'll pause their chair thank you
very much if there are any questions
from anybody
stand that might say your name for the
microphone
councilor Bell would you like me to
stand up no no no no no we don't have to
remain seated so thank you thank you
very much for that um Spencer that was
really interesting I just want I'm after
some reassurance really hate crime of
the buzzwords of the moment and um some
forces across the country have been
taking a little bit of a
I don't know wild cat approach to what
is and isn't hate crime and there have
been cases of mainly women being visited
at home by police officers for crimes
such as and I quote being untoward about
pedophiles online
so I just want to make sure that you
that everyone's aware of
Miller versus College of policing and
what does and does and does not
constitute a protected characteristic
under the equality Act
thank you thank you anybody else
heard
um thank you chairman I'll uh I I would
like to speak to the police officers
about the crime figures later on but uh
but specifically talking uh for your
presentation Spencer thank you very much
indeed for that and I have to say I I
certainly applaud the work that you're
doing but I have got a number of
questions and I hope you can help me
with it
um you said that
um when you were engaging with the
public there that uh their number one
priority was road safety and
irresponsible driving
now I find that very surprising because
um when people talk to me their number
one priority is seeing police officers
on the beat actually seeing police
and this was
um the police and crime Commissioners
number one priority more local and
visible policing that seems to have
disappeared in these new priorities
so I'm wondering what what your thoughts
are on that
um
you spoke about
um
you spoke about the road safety I'm just
looking at the oh anti-social Behavior
that's right
um looking at the force figures
anti-social behavior is recorded as
being down by 51.8 percent
in the force in in Malden it's recorded
as being down as 59 so I'm wondering why
that's a priority if if what is
happening uh is is already working so
whatever you're doing needs to be needs
to be carried on
uh I'm sorry Jim and I've got a number
of points and just carry on thank you
right uh rural crime how do we measure
those figures of rural crime because
again this is thing things that people
are asking us we can't find it from
these figures here you've spoken about
hair coursing and but things like theft
attractors theft of plant how do how do
we uh or how can this committee
um question or challenge any of those
figures if we don't have that
information
um you also spoke about hate crime
um now hate crime in the Malden area has
gone up it from 2021 from 58 cases to
106 arise
and you're these are your figures of
82.8 percent
now are those 106
nine have been solved now I'll I'll need
to speak to the police officers about
solved rates later on but as far as the
force goes
350 more offenses in 2022 up eight
percent and again 11 are solved so one
could argue that there's more being
reported
which is which is which is what we
always hear when the crime figures go up
but the bottom line is more is not being
solved uh we have now three thousand
seven hundred
police officers in Essex in fact I think
it's plus that more than we've ever had
in the history of Essex police and yet
crime
is still going up
um
again I'll take that up with with the
police officers but what I would like to
know really just to summarize is uh the
road safety aspect it seems to me we
should see more police on the beat
um ASB is or in social behavior uh is
actually at 59 in the green which I
think is good of course it's good but I
wonder why it's a priority and also how
can we measure
rural crime
foreign
[Music]
S one by one as I can remember them so
um Road Safety
um yes Road Safety when we do
um surveys gets flagged High always
um and that's why we do so much work
around those safety
um
when you said about
um
police visibility not being there on
priority two it's around driving and
down anti-social behavior in public
places with an emphasis on youth
nuisance and improving partnership
Builders ability so that is our priority
so it's not something we can you know
think when I say about improving
partnership visibility I think it's uh
in terms of policing numbers that's very
much down to the chief constable and the
police and crime commissioner but um and
I do get my high horse about police
visit about partnership visibility
sometime
in my in my in my view having a youth
worker walking around tolesbury is
probably more effective than having a
Bobby on the beat walking around
tellsbury having a community Protection
Officer walking around Promenade Park
engaging with young people is also
probably more effective than having a
police officer and I think where where
we need to move forward and I'm going to
very much leave this to the police to
report on this is partnership visibility
can be Sergeant Matt Dolby at Bradwell
on C tweeting that he is out walking
around the sea wall
and
a lot more people will see that rather
than somebody who might look out of
their curtain at the time to see if
there's a policeman there so I think in
terms of partnership visibility we need
to be a bit clearer about how we do that
but in terms of increasing police in
numbers and again I'm not going to say
anything about the police because
they'll talk about how how the numbers
are going to increase so I think that
that's important to take on board with
regards to anti-social behavior these
are our priorities for last last year so
we then look at the data this year to
see if that will still be a priority
I'm going to be slightly cynical here
um in terms of anti-social Behavior I
don't think has changed too much
we as a partnership are still dealing
with young people causing problems we're
still dealing with neighbor nuisance uh
we're still dealing with neighbors who
work from home and are clearly less
tolerant with their neighbors now
um what what we're seeing here I'd like
to be in the same position next year and
see what the reduction or increase in
anti-social behavior is because a lot of
those ASB complaints with probably been
covered breaches and things like that
and it's going to take take a while for
that to settle out so whilst on paper it
looks really good that if there's a 50
reduction I think in reality I don't
think that that is the case
I don't think there's been a massive
increase we did see increases when
lockdown released we had a lot of young
people going out into Parks drinking
alcohol taking not nitrous oxide
Etc so
um so we'll take a judge a good judgment
on that as to whether it's still there
my gut feeling is I think it should
still be there as a priority but we'll
let the data tell us and we'll analyze
the data before we make that decision
in terms of rural crime
um I think
I think the best way for this uh
committee to look at that in detail
would be perhaps for the March committee
if we invited uh Chief Inspector Terry
Bolden who looks after the rural crime
team to do a presentation similar to
what my colleagues are doing tonight
because he can give you the full detail
on that I I go to the Strategic
coordination groups I know there's been
a reduction in in hair course and I know
there's been a reduction in uh
unauthorized encampments and in terms of
Officer numbers
um I think the team's doubled hasn't it
in terms of PC numbers than from what it
was two years ago
so you know and and more importantly
that enables them to get out to the uh
businesses like Farms that enables them
to go and give the advice
um so you know but I think the actual
figures it probably be best place to the
Chief Inspector for that area uh
commented on that but we'll be more than
happy councilor heard to go away and get
those figures for you
um
finally around uh hate crime actually
quite rightly suggested hate crime has
increased
um we promote the reporting of hate
crime much more now similarly three or
four years ago when we done that around
domestic abuse the domestic abuse
figures we encourage people to report
hate crime more so that could be one
area
um you do get repeat offenses in some
areas as well and some of the work I
noticed it's not applicable to
to mold them but in Chelmsford where
I've had a big spike in hate crime one
of the main areas where that spike is is
the hospital and the mental health unit
and it's a piece of work which we're
doing the police are doing independently
around that so we are aware that we do
as a independent Advisory Group monitor
hate crime every two months uh we we
discuss it with our community groups
um I think it might be useful for me to
go away and look at the data and then
look at the victims as well
um because you'd be surprised that most
of the victims are probably white males
from hate crime in in both Champs of the
Malden so that that's something you know
we probably need to do a little bit more
work around we're in a position now
where
Essex has now got its strategic hate
crime partnership back it's been sort of
a quiet for a year or so it's been
relaunched there'll be there's a hate
crime strategy for Essex now and I'll
show you that Malden will be very much
involved in that with regards to
um the actual detection rates again it's
not something I can answer but I'll
happily let the police make a comment on
that
okay all right counselor thanks I just
can't I just come back on that please
chairman um okay just for clarity
um I certainly wasn't suggesting that
the community safety partnership was not
visible uh so I certainly wasn't
speaking about that because it because
it is visible uh and the other thing
that I I would like to see on the
figures if possible
um is to have a bar chart because the
figures that you present at the moment
uh
you can't really compare
Malden to ethelsford to bed I mean
obviously it's going to be bigger in in
Basildon and chelms it of course it is
uh but it but I would just like to see
um those figures produced uh in a bar
chart to see where we're going
but I would like to come back to the
police officers when it's my turn
chairman thank you
yeah so first first of all
um I would like to thank Spencer for
such a clear report and outlining all
the good things that you're doing with
crucial crew and all of that really
useful information I've got a couple of
questions I've got some questions
afterwards on the figures which I'll
leave until we've had the police
officers report but I would like to go
to the um CSP update and to Pages 13 and
14. and
3.3.1 we've got at the end of that the
community policing team will also have a
harbor MDC offices which will assume
which will comprise of one sergeant and
six police constables and I know we've
spoken before on this because my
question was about the accessibility of
the police station that we have there
um because both some some of us and
members of the public have actually
found it quite difficult sometimes they
have to wait to see if somebody comes in
and out of the station it's not always
easy to attract attention so will that
be more accessible do you know with a
front desk I know that Richard Holmes
was looking at that so I don't know what
the answer to that was
in terms of uh
um policing numbers again I think the
police will update on that okay I can
introduce you to the sergeant here this
is this is such a met Dolby so he will
be looking after moldum going forward
um so I've delivered on that promise uh
in terms of uh um accessibility uh I
think that's the conversation we need to
have I think the district council
offices are uh more more accessible now
obviously we've been gone for a two-year
period of having the vaccinations coming
out the front there but it's a I think
it's a discussion we need to have with
the police and I'm sure we can come to
an amicable Arrangement so it can be
improved counselor okay and there was
one other question which I know you were
already already did know about which um
I've referred here to 3.3.3 on page 14
if anyone wants to any members want to
look at that
um and it really regards
um heybridge actually because and I
think it's something that could end up
happening with other parishes I hope not
um but we're looking here at you know
the cseo works closely with CEOs and the
try services were all funded by police
so as you probably are aware and we've
got a situation with haybridge Parish
Council where they have they have ended
their contractors at the end of this
month I believe with our CET team and
have actually gone down the line of um
putting out an advert for their own ASB
type officer I don't want to sort of
name the role incorrectly so my question
was really with regard to what will
happen then with heybridge with regard
to the partnership and how that will
carry on what the degree of work will be
with somebody being employed by the
parish instead of Borden District
Council because I just wasn't I wasn't
and heybridge obviously is an area of
some concern as you're probably aware
we've had a number of fires in the woods
some of those caused by anti-social
Behavior so I've got all kinds of
worries around that and I know there are
other heybridge members in here as well
tonight so I I just be yeah grateful for
your views on that thank you
yeah thank you Council I mean it's
obviously disappointing that heybridge
power should make that decision
um just you know just just disappointing
um we we as a community safety
partnership it will make no difference
really as to what we do there we will
continue like next week we'll be there
doing our community engagement day
marking bikes so that that will continue
I'll still be continuing with uh
discussions around uh using Plantation
Halls uh
um one of our redeployable cameras which
is one of the discussions we've already
had with the parish
um we it's difficult for me to speculate
on what will happen with the new role
um all I will say is uh all of our
community uh engagement officers are
credited with Essex police that
accreditation is with Malden District
Council I'm not aware of any parishes in
s
who are have accredited officers working
um as part of that role so it will be
interesting to see
what powers that officer would have
um it'd be similar to loads of private
security firm I think again I'm
speculating I don't know but but that's
some something I think we'd need to take
into account but you know uh
if you know it's probably not wise for
me to you know give a full response on
that but um you know in terms of the
work we do as a partnership with them
there'll be no change really and uh it's
so you know so it won't things people
like Les in the picture there is a try a
service officer there'll be no changes
result of that they just won't have the
um additional you know enforcement
things like truecam Etc
um I should imagine that but I'm you
know it's probably not in the role role
to give that full response so I won't
want to speculate but that would be my
views on the matter
thank you very much Spencer that's
appreciated thank you
thank you
um councilor Morgan councilor for wooden
Wickham Bishops and wooden Ward
um thank you Mr Clark for your
presentation and I I really sort of
coming on from councilor herds quite
really I've been elected since February
and the one point that every Parish
Council makes to me when I go to see
them is the concern over speeding in
this uh in in the ward and the
perception of maybe unfair I don't know
that Essex police are not doing anything
about it
so I think there's a degree of
um work to be done here to to sort of
reinforce and and to reassure those
people and and the residents that they
represent that there is something being
done and I mean you say there's six
thousand people have been brought to
speak I don't think many of those were
necessarily in my world we're very
surprised at work and the great thing
for example is the fact you know the
extension of Technology you're saying
about true care Etc well you know great
if we can have those you know if that
those can be rolled out throughout the
area then that would be welcome but as I
say there is a perception that Essex
police are not doing anything about this
feeling problem in the world
um when we talk about uh traffic
enforcement it's very much down to the
safer Essex roads partnership uh I
believe at the last meeting we had at
Madame pipuda is the head of Rhodes
police and give a very good presentation
um about two weeks ago they've done a
sort of surround the town uh
um thing for Malden where there was an
incredible amount of enforcement uh what
I'll try and do is pick out the figures
for you from that obviously what they
tend to do is they tend to
choose a town or a city to do some
additional enforcement work and moldum
was subject to that only a couple of
weeks ago so I'll try and get those
statistics but I will take on board your
comments working Bishops anything we can
do as a district council anything we can
do with the community such as Community
speed watch I'll be more than happy and
happy to have that conversation with you
outside the meeting around them
can I take counselor Morley because he's
been waiting then I'll come back to you
thank you Jim yeah thank you Spence for
that report
um three things well first of all I
would like to thank the police or and
whoever is involved with the hair
coursing in particular
um being a farmer is quite an
intimidating and can be quite violent
and frightening thing
and it's funny you brought that up
because I've just noticed in the last
year I've uh hairs across our farm I've
never seen so many
so something's definitely happening but
it is quite a nasty excuse me violent
thing to go through confronting him in
the dark
often on your own I know you probably
shouldn't do it but you just do it's
natural interesting
so I'd like to thank you on that and and
whatever you've done keep keep going
um as regards the pandemic do you see
that continuing on with working from
home is that a feature as well
with um violence and poverty because
they're using the heating obviously
whereas before they'd be in the office
so that was your
views on that and also fly tipping do
you have figures is that up or down the
same
and being in the waste business myself
is there still a stop and check vehicles
for Waste carriers license it's
particularly small Transit you know
little dodgy skip blowers and things is
that still going on
um any figures thank you
thank you counselor um so our feedback
the
um your views About Hair course enough
to the Royal team I will thank uh
um yeah and I I think it's something
about 56 it's down or something like
that but it's certainly been doing a lot
of work around that and I I constantly
follow the police on Twitter whenever
whenever they've had a successful uh uh
catch uh they always feed that back
um I mean it is it's not just about the
hits don't get me wrong I love it here
but it's what goes with it most
certainly
um in terms of trade waste inspections
yes we still do that the community
engagement officers regularly work with
a rural engagement team I remember
earlier in the year we worked at
Plantation Hall so any cars coming down
there we're pulling in the Vans and
doing inspection of licenses so a lot of
that's going on still again we we done a
day of that during the street week which
we've done in August so again working
with the Royal Engagement team I've done
the trade carriers licenses flight
tipping um
yeah I mean it's it's a difficult thing
to tackle I mean fortunately
um I don't think molden suffers as much
as some of the other areas in Essex a
lot of the people who do the fly tipping
come out of London and so we have areas
like farrak and eppin uh probably get
the worst of it
and it's something really really
difficult to challenge because you can
guarantee even if you put something like
uh
um covert cameras in or ampr they're
probably working on false plates anyway
so it's it's catching them as they do it
and uh but again it's something we do
tackle uh we we tackle it uh the war
engagement team tackle and the Enviro I
mean environment agency work alongside
as well for the major fly tips as well
so work is going on around that thank
you
councilor heard I think it's just a
brief I'm sorry to have a second bite
the Cherry that's all right
just that um
with cancer Morley talking about
speeding in Malden High straight and
down down the hill we have a 20 mile an
hour
speed limit
um have we had any prosecutions at all
can anybody help you with that any
prosecutions at all for those areas
I think my simple answer for that
councilorities I I do not know the
answer to that question but I'd be more
than happy to speak with the relevant
people to see what we can get from them
thank you
any more questions
thank you very much Spencer much
appreciated
thank you for that and there we move and
sorry Anne
sorry you're gonna have to wait for the
things
and
that's right just an update uh there is
some fly tipping in goldhanger you know
the real big house where the S Bend is
just the other side of gold hanger on
the right there's someone's dumped a lot
of stuff there
um have we actually I don't know who
this is to ask the police or yourself
have we got any Community Police sport
officers still
you're talking about pcsos
yes we do yeah
it's just that we used to have um a
Romanian girl I don't know she's left
now but she was absolutely brilliant
and we haven't really got that contact
anymore I know when Gary was doing it
um until he resigned
um he got a lot of confidence and
whatever from the youngsters and we did
have a present presentation not so long
ago by Sue green and is it Lee
he just seemed to be going on about dog
poo which was a
although it's probably a priority
somewhere I don't know
I think there's a lot more going on in
haybridge drug wise and everything else
than a bit adult poo
um but yeah I mean the
that the people that you will be talking
about visualization on the streets she
used to be really really good and I
presume with haybridge Parish Council
taking on a full-time I don't know what
they're going to call him
um they're going to give him a van as
well
but I presume we're going to get the
visualization through him but I think
you're right that we're going to lose
the true cam aspect because none of them
are trained and obviously they're not
going to have any relationship with the
police
so I don't know how we're going to get
on with that
perhaps I'll ask the BMP
thank you
just
to answer one perspective of that so
under which you'll probably encapsulate
some of the other bits and I don't want
to steal Sergeant orbee's Thunder who's
prepared a nice presentation for you but
with the new one in five it's actually
one and five not one in six officers
come into modern town center team
the hope is that we will be able to
bring a pcso into that team as well
one hasn't been factored into the team
at the moment but we do have pcsos that
cover Chelmsford and Malden as a whole
and there are two pcsos that do
regularly come out into the rural areas
but they cover
the entirety of Malden District which
covers South Woodham Ferris as well so
they do come out but it's unfortunately
it's one of those unless you've probably
got your nose pressed up against the
window and they actually drive past your
house at the time you have your nose
pressed up against the window you may
not see them but they are out and about
quite regularly and the truecam
um speeding cameras
regardless of whether they're coming out
of the council what what we can do is if
there are members of the public that
wish to become part of the community
speed watch they can sign up to it for a
sixth place they can be trained and then
they can they can go out and do the
speed watch as well
but we do have so you we do have
Community speed watch members around the
LPA who do use the true Cam and what
happens is uh if if you don't know how
it works they they might catch somebody
speeding and because they're not police
officers they can't stop them they can't
give them a ticket but what they do is
take the details take the registration
and a letter will go out to them to say
we've caught you speeding and if it's
you know if it happens again your
details will be sent over to the police
and then that's how we
take it further forward
I just come back chairman that sounds
like a cunning plan
um
also
you're talking I don't know if it's true
grant but you know that the partnership
thing where you get the police
um
what's the word basically you got the
police there but you've also got the
public who have been trained to use it
they used to do that along yeah they
used to do that along
[Music]
um
cool thing not gold hanger Colchester
Road but I seems to have died to death
so the um the community's the community
speed watch people
unfortunately when kovitz
hit and lockdown happened it was
withdrawn and it was suggested that
because a lot of the trained members of
public for Community speed watch were of
an elderly
nature that they were sitting in the
high risk category so therefore it was
withdrawn and nobody was asked to go out
and do any Community speed watch because
of covid and because of regulations and
because of safety so it's been
reintroduced but it's about training up
more people and getting people out and
wanting to do it and they can either go
out as a group of people themselves or
they can go out with an officer
thanks for that so Spencer can we
actually
so I'll highlight that
respect on next week when you're down at
the plantation Hall see if we can get
some volunteers to take that up yeah
yeah most certainly councilor I mean
I've got the email address for the
person at the fire service who
operates the community speed watch
scheme and it's uh action inspector
um Chief Inspector first and pointed out
I think it's
volunteer the volunteer base
um coming back from the pandemic in in
almost every area whilst whilst it's
been brilliant throughout the pandemic
we're fine and even things like Street
pastors
um because a lot of the street passes we
have uh in their older years their high
risk groups and they don't want to do it
anymore
um so it's I think it's it's going to
take a while to build again but most
certainly next week it's something we
can look at
um by by all means and it's also I don't
think I really uh um finished off when
we spoke about the access to the build
to the building the police station here
we're we're more than happy to have that
conversation with the police in any way
we can improve that we we will
reiterate there at this stage I think so
with the new team coming in that might
be a good opportunity to change it
yeah because I hope about the access to
the police station I've tried a couple
of times to ring the bell and whatever
and I think I grew another year older
but uh also that's the only lift
facility which is now within the police
area
so if some if if whenever anyone wanted
to get in with any sort of disability
they couldn't get upstairs so that was a
bit bit naughty
but um
I'm thinking ahead now the CVS
they have people keep volunteering for
different stuff
I think that might be a an Avenue that
you could look at
right now the question for councilor
hoopner please
please uh so sorry just to thank you Mr
chairman just following up on Council
Bill's point I mean the um the
publication or some sort of you know
publicity for this uh you know getting
these teams back on I mean because I
wasn't aware of that so I'm down to a
lot of other people around so can I urge
whoever is responsible for that to get
out and spread the word
all right okay thank you very much again
Spencer I can finally say thank you we
now move on to sorry Mr
chair
oh I'll take that
um thank you for your question uh
councilor bill
um in regards to hate crime um hate
crime is specifically defined
um and it's a very clear definition as
to what hate crime is
um also there's a whole list as you know
protected characteristics
um in regards to your example about
um
women being accused of
saying something about a painful
I mean perhaps if I can just clarify um
there is a fear and certainly some
police forces not all but some police
forces appear to have been captured by
gender ideology and they have received
training from organizations such as
Stonewall and the LGBT Foundation
that misrepresents the protected
characteristics
and includes gender identity in that
list whereas the actual protected
characteristic is
gender reassignment as you know this has
resulted in police
well going knocking on people's doors
and in some cases arresting them for
hate crimes such as misgendering someone
on social media and this is a great
great concern to a lot of people it is
disproportionately women that are
finding their getting these visits and I
just want some reassurance that Essex
police are going to apply the law not
what is colloquially referred to as
Stonewall law when you're dealing with
hate crime because I hope that clarifies
yeah absolutely cancer but I can't
reassure you having worked on Chelsea
the modern CPT
a sergeant for the last three years when
we deal with hate crime that's one of
the
one of the the types of crime that we
specifically deal with I can reassure
you that that's not happening we
specifically apply the definition
and we specifically deal with those
matters concerning the protected
characteristics as you mentioned
it's very reassuring Sergeant Dobby
thank you very much for that thank you
yeah right okay
right we move on now to the police
performance update presented by Sergeant
Matt Dolby and
Chief Inspector Kelly first in acting as
a commander I believe is that right
misrepresent yourself
carry on you too
I'm actually not going to do the
presentation I'm going to let Sergeant
Matt Shelby do it because he's put the
presentation together and he's going to
be your your he's the new sergeant for
the new town center team so it's a good
way for him to introduce himself and
and get affiliated with yourself so I'm
I'm just here to answer the awkward
questions yeah
okay good evening everybody my name is
Sergeant Matt dalway I'm the new modern
town team sergeant and that time has
been operational for the past couple of
weeks
um just by way of an introduction prior
to that I was a sergeant over at
Chelmsford road in CPT and held that
position for three years and I've got 19
years police experience working in a
variety of roles
um so I'll go on to the the police
report
um for the Malden District
um if I can go to the next slide please
um so this is this is just a false plan
just to um
give you a little bit on that our main
effort is around victims violence and
vulnerability and visibility and that
sets our priorities
um within the plan
um rape and serious sexual abuse is one
of them domestic abuse
um drug and alcohol related violence
child abuse and exploitation violence
against women and girls hate crime
Berkeley and robbery
serious and organized crime death and
serious injury stalking and harassment
and business fraud and cybercrime
so that's our main focus for the um the
upcoming year if I could have the next
slide please
um unfortunately there has been an
increase in crime as we all know overall
across Essex there's been an increase of
8.3 percent over the last 12 months
um at the Malden District has seen an
increase in crime 5.2 overall
um with an increase of 7.7 in relation
to victim crime and a reduction state
crime of 6.2 percent
uh next slide please
um violent crime which includes violence
with injury homicide stalking and
harassment
um
it also includes violence without injury
death or Serious injury caused by
unlawful driving is up by 9.4 in Malden
and the main areas that we've seen
around those increases are in relation
to violence with and without injury
next slide please
just in comparison
um with the rest of Essex you could say
Morgan's sitting there at 5.2 percent
um so in 10th spot there
and as you can see there's there's an
increase across the force
um next slide please
we've had a reduction in crime however a
personal robbery is down by 8.3 percent
fifth bar shot lifting is down by 29.4
theft from vehicles are down by 14.5
percent
if the pedal cycle is down by 18.2
percent and deaf and serious injury on
our roads there's been no change in that
there's been two for this period so that
remains
um
level
um ASB is down 61.8 of the figures that
um
I was provided with
moving on to solved crime solved weights
and sexual offenses are up 11.1 overall
um solve rates in relation to theft
offenses or up by 57.1 percent
vehicle faces included interference so
up to
133.3 and solved rates for theft are up
by 41.7 percent
um possession of weapons are up by 112.5
but that's mainly due to proactive
policing and stop searching and using
those Powers
um obviously if we search for somebody
and we find the weapon the crime is
generated it gets detected Etc
why has crime increased in modern
um there's a lot of theories as to why
crime does increase they're obviously
complex
um population increase peer pressure
drug and alcohol abuse
poverty unemployment
there's lots of Dynamics which play the
part in there and whilst crime has
increased it has decreased in certain
areas Malden is below the overall Essex
increase
by 2.9 percent
I think I might have gone ahead of
myself a little bit so I do apologize
um Tara
um what does Malden look like in terms
of policing so modern enjoys
24-hour seven day a week local policing
team coverage so they're your emergency
response officers
five shifts have been working across the
year
in addition more than supported by the
criminal investigation department the
domestic abuse teams
and the community policing times
um
there's also
we've got a lot of volunteer officers
that provide coverage to Malden as well
and within the modern District we know
it's a large rural area we've got the
rural engagement team which Spencer's
already spoken about previously they've
grown in numbers and we've seen some
excellent work that they've been
performing recently
I've got the Marine unit
as well I'm also pleased to say that the
Malden town team which I'm the new
sergeant of is now operational we've
been working at Malden Police Station
um at the minute we've got myself and
three constables
team's growing we should be at full
capacity by December this year
um
Spence has already touched on it but
we've got the community engagement and
safety officer
um dedicated to the Malden area and
we've got the tri-service officer who
was already spoken about
um
we've also got those support units as
well that provide a service to Malden as
I said we've got the Marine unit we've
got our disruptor units which
um this they go out disrupting
criminality we've got our Operational
Support Group based at Borum and we can
obviously call those specialist Assets
in when needed
um Spencer's already explained what the
community engagement safety officer does
so I won't go on too much about that but
Rosie does fantastic work
uh working collaboratively with the
community safety partnership
um and other partners
again the try Service Officer Lindsay
does great work
offers advice from crime protection fire
prevention tactics and techniques and
he's also trying to first responder and
he's actually acquired some really good
intelligence recently which has led to
the acquisition onwards which we've
executed in the in the district
we've got a dedicated schools operation
um
and the Chelmsford and Malden CPT and
their Town Center teams we deployed
daily to the secondary and primary
schools within the Malden District where
the operational demand allows so that's
been running for about two years now
we've got database for the schools
within the district
um and we go down that database
visiting all of the schools the other
day we was all saying to school in
Malden we visited the plume School the
other day so as a new team
I'm looking to build those relationships
within the schools
um and we've already had some fantastic
feedback in regards to that
um there are quite often a lot of
complaints in relation to the schools
around driving and parking at school
drop off and pick up times
um I've already taken that on board as
an issue and I am speaking with the
enforcement manager and the parking
attendance within the council and we're
going to do some joint work visiting
those schools and taking some
enforcement action
um so yeah the modern town team as I say
we are we are operational
um
and I'll just come back to a point I
think somebody mentioned in regards to
visible policing
um it's a real passion of mine to get
out there on the boat
um we've been out
across the districts we was out in
Malden High Street
regularly over the past two weeks and
the local residents and the businesses
the feedback has been brilliant they're
really happy to see us out there
um the times have been really visible
for the last last two weeks since the
since the Inception of the town's home
and as I say the the comments that we've
seen on Facebook has been really really
positive
um next slide please
um where are we
okay also I've got a dedicated Malden
neighborhood watch phone
um what that is it was identified quite
some time ago that an opened watch
coordinators were
um they had some really good
intelligence to give us but
they were really one zero one on the
non-emergency line and by the time
they'd got through to somebody whatever
they was witnessing had passed so we've
devised a dedicated hotline for one of
the better phrase all of the
neighborhood watch coordinators for the
modern District are on it
um
and if they've got issues or any
concerns
like Ping a message through to the phone
and then whoever's holding that phone
it's normally the community safety and
engagement officer or the sergeant and
they will review the information and
they will deploy officers to it if need
be
um so what work has been done recently
um
this is just within the in the past
couple of weeks
um
we regularly get incoming emails from
members of the public within the
district this particular one was
concerning anti-social Behavior over a
location called The Furs in London
office is deployed straight away to deal
with those issues
foreign
next slide please
Marine unit has been in the river
Blackwater
um they've been conducting patrols and
offering safety advice
rural engagement team they've been out
in ashwoodem
um there was a 999 event there recently
really good Community engagement
um
so that was that was really good to see
we've got offices there patrolling
Burnham and Crouch and north fanbridge
um another 999 event that you can see
there that was that was put on
for Community engagement
we've also had some weeks of
intensification recently one being the
ASB awareness week and a straight week
has Spencer mentioned
um
it was really good uh Chase
superintendent was out
um we spoke with lots of people about
ASP making them aware how to report it
um and the straight week was an
intensification period around all local
issues that we could uh try to deal with
within that week so we saw a range of
tactics implemented
to deal with it
next slide there that's one of the new
offices in the Malden town team uh Pacey
Bogle she's there at Morrisons in
regards to hate crime Awareness Week
um and we were there educating residents
and businesses around what hate crime is
how to report it and what impact such
crime can have
and we've also been presenting at the
secondary schools
um around hate crime as well
moving on it's been National Speed
campaign
Awareness Week Grace at least so you can
say offices there conducting speed
checks
um within London that one was
um four drivers were reported for excess
speed high speed recorders was 48 miles
an hour and a 30 limit
um just touching them
let's Dennis the try Service Officer he
as well as our community safety
engagement officer they come up with
some fast fantastic intelligence around
uh drug dealing in the tollsbury area
um as a result of that the modern town
team in conjunction with
some other teams within Essex police
executed a warrant and addressed in
Salisbury it was a positive warrant so
that was great work
um we've had issues in Burnham people
have been concerned at the train station
so we've deployed their conducting foot
Patrols in the Burnham on Crouch area
foreign
this is one of our school visits which
we did recently at All Saints primary
school the next door Nursery asked to
come in and talk to the children which
we did and then it was really good it's
fantastic to engage with the children
and the staff there
um just going touching on I know spading
has been raised with the new modern town
team when we're
fully operational I've already got a
training requesting for all those
officers to be trained in
um speed gun usage so they'll be
deployed to various areas within the
district
um and we will be out there conducting
spay checks
um I think it was your self counselor
herd you asked about the highest rate
and we said we don't have the figures
just to touch on that the other
um even in last week
we was on foot patrol getting the modern
High Street
and a vehicle literally sped past us I
would estimate the speed to be about 50
miles an hour we couldn't be forced to
speed because we had no device at the
time we wasn't checking for the the
actual speed but that vehicle was
stopped and the vehicle got seized for
no insurance so there has been an
enforcement action taken around the
manner of the driving but not
necessarily the Spades but he received
six points 200 pound fine on his license
um and we've got plans in place to do
further operations in the High Street
with our special constabulary
um so that's my presentation thank you
everybody for listening
we've got any questions please
counselor
right
um
thank you very much indeed
um
I appreciate the the information about
the the vehicle that was stopped you
know that's uh that is that is good news
now you've spoken a lot about the
various different uh things that are
happening uh the Marine unit and the the
tri-service officer Etc
but the proof of the pudding
is in the figures and those are the
figures that I want to I want to speak
about because
um
just for your information I sit on the
police and crime panel and I regularly
challenge the police and crime
commissioner on the figures for Essex
and all crime in Essex is up by 10 but
tonight I'm specifically concerned about
the Malden District
so all crime in Northern has gone up by
8.5 percent you've spoken you've spoken
about that there are no increase in
solved rates
acting based crime is up 11 percent
violence against the person is up 12.6
percent
sexual offenses are up
27.4 percent
robberies are up by seven percent
theft is up by 18 burglary up by 17
vehicle theft is up by 24.6 and hate
crime as we know has has increased
my concern is that with all the things
that are going on
crime isn't being solved
we are we are recording more crimes
but we're not solving any well we're not
solving enough
uh I understand the issues and the
problems because I've spent 30 years in
the police myself so I understand uh the
problems that there are
but I think that these figures
are showing that whatever's going on
isn't working because crime is rising
solved rates are going down
and I'm wondering if you could help me
why that is
in terms of the solved rates there's
obviously there's 22 different outcomes
that we can apply to an investigation
with obviously charged people we postal
acquisition people in the post
um we give out our call disposal options
so there's so many different ways that
we can dispose of a crime and it's my
understanding and I'm sure Chief
Inspector will correct me but some of
those historic
outcomes that would normally be used to
be included in the solved figures have
since been removed we don't use them
anymore
that could be one of the reasons
um
but we can only I mean we crime can only
be solved if if the evidence is there to
support the full Code test
um and
if that evidence isn't there to solve it
then we just unfortunately cannot solve
that crime
we do experience as well there's people
often report crime but then they don't
they don't engage in the process of
cooperating with the police in terms of
evidence so that will be outcomed as a
particular outcome and it won't be
solved obviously it won't be a solved
mark
so that's the difficulty there you've
got anything else on it
so there are lots of ways so so as
sergeant Dolby has said there's lots of
different ways that we can outcome
offenses and some of our outcomes we
class as a positive outcome but don't
necessarily sit under a solved rate so
we can positively outcome a crime so say
for instance a crime gets reported in a
school
we're not in the business of
criminalizing children unless they need
to be criminalized we are not in the
business of criminalizing them because
what we don't want is in 10 years time
to have a society of
adults young adults mid-20s who have all
been criminalized when they were younger
for
potentially mistakes that they've made
as a child so we don't want to
criminalize them which has been done in
the past so we're not in the we're not
in the business of doing that so we will
look to positively outcome the offense
but it won't be by charge or Postal
requisition or anything like that it may
well be that we've directed them to
um
a different service to a charity to the
youth offending team and sometimes by
diverting them to another team or
another area or another partner for them
to take control and deal with it that's
a positive outcome but it's not a solved
rate so we would dispose of that crime
effectively on our system file it as a
positive outcome because we have done
something about it we haven't just gone
or we're not interested in that we're
going to let it go but it's not been
solved as in we haven't sent them to
court or we haven't charged them or
cautioned them or something like that
and also within our figures what it
doesn't show is it shows the figures of
um Mrs miggins is a victim and there
might be 10 records related to Mrs
miggins with all from the same offense
but different suspects and that will all
count towards a rise in the figures so
they'll all show as a rising crime and
unfortunately we are going to see a
rising crime because of the cost of
living crisis that that is naturally and
and I I know everyone comments and says
about the cost of living crisis is
coming I think the cost of living crisis
is here and has been here for quite a
few months
and that has definitely had an impact on
the rise of crime
I'll come back on it thank you yes I
know Mrs Megan's and I know that she has
been uh constantly uh
um assaulted and stolen from Etc so can
I can you just confirm
um inspector that uh all burglaries are
attended by officers
so Essex police has a
um as a strict policy that all
burglaries will be attended by police
officers now I I can't comment whether
that that is
strictly adhered to what I can say is
that our policies that all burglaries
will be attending by an officer now it
may well be that
that's lapsed over the last few months I
don't know and I can't comment on that
but as of as of now there is a firm
um footing in place to say that all
officers or all burglaries will be
attended by a police officer and that is
Essex police's pledge
thank you so I have some more questions
if I may write
um the other thing that you spoke about
uh you've got many volunteer officers in
Malden town I know that Malden Town
Council has three vacancies for paid
specials which haven't been filled for
some time so if you do know of anybody
they can be financed the money is
already there for them
um I'm just a little bit concerned that
you're asked you're telling me about
these solved outcomes are you saying
that we can't rely on these figures
because it's telling me that there are
the most sold rates are reduced or very
low are you saying that these figures
are not correct no the figures are
correct for solved rates but I what you
have to understand is a solved rate is
something where we've sent somebody to
court or we've so we've charged somebody
postal requisition to them giving them a
caution a conditional caution or
something like that that's a solved
right so the figures are correct on the
solved rates what the solved rate won't
tell you is what a positive outcome has
been where we've diverted somebody to
another partner or an outside agency or
something like that that doesn't sit
under a solved rate because that is not
a solved crime
right thank you that through through you
chairman then uh then I don't really
think that this committee can have that
confidence in those figures if they're
not reflecting the true picture this
committee is here
um to scrutinize
what is happening in the area and I
don't feel that I'm getting the correct
picture because what it's saying to me
is that that of all of the crime in uh
in Malden
um only 8.5 of it is actually solved
now that can't be right
3864 offenses and 371 solved 8.2 percent
uh same with violence against the person
1941 offenses 158 solved
so so this so yes the solved rate is
correct so what they're saying is the
solved rate is correct we've solved
those crimes we've got a suspect on the
end of it we've charged them or we've
cautioned them or we've given them a
conditional caution
it so we've solved that crime if we have
a crime that comes in that we say we're
going to it's uh for going back to a
child that's committed a crime and we
send them over to a partner then they
get dealt with my partner that is an
unsolved crime it's a positive outcome
because we've done something but we have
not solved the crime there's a
difference between a positive outcome
and this solved crime
okay I've I've almost almost finished it
I think somebody's got there right
um
what I see on on the figures in front of
me is as usual a sea of red
I see it not only on Force Level
um but I see it uh in in Malden as well
um and really to be properly measured
then we need to see more green on there
now I'm not quite sure how you how
you're going to do it but I don't think
that these figures are truly reflecting
what is happening an example is if you
have a 50 cut in robberies that means
that we've had two
or one instead of two that's and I know
that I've spoken with Spencer before
about how these how these figures don't
truly reflect
um
the the actual case what what I will say
is
um that uh
well I can't say that because that was
that's to do with the crime commissioner
but they're talking about a very very
high
feedback of 89 satisfaction with the
police
but I'm sorry but that's not what I'm
hearing
you know I I support the police as much
as anybody else but we need to see more
people out on the beat and we need to
see some of these crime figures down
because that's what people are being
measured on
um and just finally
um have you finally got your interview
room here a dedicated interview room
which has been promised
for some for at least three years that
I've been asking for it
there is an interview room here where
suspects get interviewed if that's what
you're referring to is it is it a
dedicated police room for you no it's
not an office that you borrow no it's a
dedicated room I've actually been
sitting in there today they've got
mobile interview equipment and suspects
coming to the police station they're
interviewed in accordance with posts I'm
very pleased that that's actually
happened uh so so well done for that and
I hope that all the new lockers that
arrived recently will indicate a lot
more police officers here
and therefore increase the visibility
thank you chairman councilor Bill
finally
thank you Mr chairman I did want to
forget you I know I know I know you
wouldn't listen
um I'm I work with looked after children
so I'm not a fan of criminalizing
children as you might imagine and I'm
and this is this is actually what I want
to hear I don't want to hear about
people being locked up I want to hear
about people addressing the issues
behind their crimes I want to hear about
people with substance misuse issues
getting help so they don't reoffend and
you know children getting
but please is there and I appreciate
it's difficult because of all the
partner agencies involved as councilor I
heard and said you guys are doing
yourself a disservice here is there any
way we can capture all this good work
that's going on because yeah I'd much
rather someone who's had a 10-year
heroinhabitants got a you know 56
offenses goes into rehab gets support
doesn't offend again then they get
banged up again because it's a better
long-term solution but we must be able
to capture that in order to reassure
ourselves and our residents
big ask but is it possible thank you
I don't know how so obviously we don't
run the data ourselves it goes through
our analysts it's something that we can
ask I don't know
I don't know how possible it is I don't
know how frequently it can be run I
don't know is the honest answer but it's
certainly something I can ask for
that
so yeah just briefly come back because
yeah it looks bad and it's not and and
you know we want to restore but we know
faith in you guys is taking a bit of
battery we want to restore that so any
way that we can do that I would be
absolutely yep I can certainly ask the
question and see if we can have a look
at our what we call a positive outcome
so it might not be a solved outcome but
it would be positive dealing with
something I'll have a look into it for
you councilor Mays
thank you Mr chairman
um yeah I've got a just a couple of um
areas I'm quite interested in knife
crime
um
concerns me greatly
yeah stabbings are not good
um I can't find in any of the data that
we've been provided any information on
stop search and
the link between stop search and then
um uh recovery of knives
um so that would be interesting to know
where we're at with that
I attended crucial crew this year for
the first time wow Blown Away
absolutely fantastic and I would urge
every single member here today next year
to to try and Shadow a session because
knife crime was one of the things that
that we did cover or that they covered
um I'm also interested you talked about
Sergeant Dolby about engaging with
schools I'd be interested in it in how
you're actually doing that you know is
it just going into the reception or is
it actually going into the playgrounds
and sports Fields Etc
um
you also talked about a dedicated uh
watch line with neighborhood watch I'd
like just a little bit more information
maybe you could send that to me
um I don't need to necessarily an answer
here and now thank you Mr chairman thank
you Council specially
yes so really
um listening to what other members are
saying as well and I know it's not
something that you're perhaps directly
responsible for but I think one of the
problems and I'm a new member so I was
elected and only only in April of this
year and kept looking at this for the
first time it just looks like a a data
run there's very little analysis or or
explanation and somebody did send me a
really useful link which I know was
passed on on to you Matt um from the LGA
research so where so for example and
you're probably not going to be able to
see it in here but you get maps
comparing figures nationally for Rural
crime and it gives you a bit of a better
perspective and also
um you know you're able to look at the
it did show for example that from 2018
to now it's rag rated in four different
categories and we've moved from Green
right up to whether it's like a second
Amber so just under red now so in terms
of crime numbers for a victim-based
crime and so that is sort of that that's
that gives you an overall perspective
and and when you've just got pages of
data just based on Essex and you've got
cities in there as well as rural areas
it didn't feel because we are a scrutiny
committee it did seem a little bit
um
difficult to process so I don't know if
it's just feedback for Essex police
generally that and I think taking on
bought everything that councilor Bell
said and that councilman mazes said it
would be lovely to hear a bit more
because those presentations we get are
great but a bit more about what the
figures are relating to because actually
as a reporter many years ago I actually
went to see one of them and reported on
one of the very first crucial Crews many
decades ago
um in Brentwood and um it was it was
fantastic and it'd be so so good to have
a little bit more you know around data
well I don't know how you provide data
on that but certainly data with regard
to how you're dealing with children in
the schools
um and some feedback even from schools
and that kind of thing and I realized
you know it's asking a lot of you
because you have you know you've got to
dedicate yourselves to fighting crime
but I don't know if there's a way that
Essex could make reports generally that
were a bit better than a standard
data run that I think doesn't tell us a
huge amount and that that's that that's
just just feedback because what I've
heard here tonight has actually been
really encouraging that having looked
just at this I was actually quite
concerned so that's that's the that's
just just what I'd say thank you
thank you Mr chairman um the haybridge
garden suburb is about to start being
constructed so the population of mall
that's gonna be increasing I was just
wondering whether the Manning levels
that you've sort of students has been
have been put together with that in mind
I I don't know is the answer to that the
what the Staffing levels that we've got
for the response teams are
um staying the same and the uplift is
for the town center team but you've
still got the CPT team that cover
Chelmsford and Malden as well so
although we've got the town center team
who run out of Malden the CPT team ran
out of Chelmsford but they cover
Chelmsford and Malden right so so the
future sort of population level doesn't
come into the deep Manning planning with
us I don't know if there's anything on
the horizon to put more offices in mold
and I don't know is the answer to that
that's that's not something that I get
involved in
councilor Morley
thank you chairman
um it does strike me that as Society
changes the figures fluctuate and
people's
with the cost of living crisis but
I think we've somehow got to try and
stop it at some kind of source and like
there was some of my fellow councils
were saying with schools
is the future canopy a program but
perhaps you spend one someone once a
month or whatever in a school trying to
I don't know how you're going to do it
but it what sort of plans do you have or
are there any really for that for
stopping it at source really I think
I know it's appearance but
so
I can I can answer
some of the stuff around the schools
schools are quite tricky because some
schools will interact with us in a very
supportive of us going in and speaking
to the children and being involved in
things in some schools believe it or not
are not so
supportive
um and we have within the within the LPA
not not modern within Chelmsford and
Malden we have a a lot of schools over
90 primary schools all together and then
we've got I think
just under 30 I think secondary schools
around that
and we try and cover all of this goals
but
um we go from a school that will give us
full access and give us lanyards and
access into the school we don't have to
make an appointment we can go into the
school we can walk around the school and
we can in we can sit and have lunch with
the children if we want to and we go
from a school that's that supportive to
we have a school on the other
end of the scale who if we attend
without having made an appointment the
head teacher will make a complaint about
it
so we have we have two opposite ends of
the scale that is very difficult to to
kind of
deal with all of the schools in the same
way so so one of the things that I've
tried to do and one of the things that
we're hoping to do amongst the CPT and
then the Malden town center team is
sit in on what is called the mesh which
is the meeting that is attended by all
of the head teachers of the secondary
schools
and by sitting in on that that means
that I can speak to the Head teachers
directly and explain that instead of
seeing it as the police that come into
the school and it's all negative because
it we're we're setting those up as being
an outlier for the problems that are
being caused we want all of them to sign
up and say yes come and visit our school
come and come whenever you would like
come and talk to the students and
I think because Society has changed and
because
children seem to be a little bit less
reactive to
um
to their elders and then they perhaps
were when when I was younger they're
very much more
um
they're not afraid to speak their mind
they're not afraid to question authority
they're not afraid to to sort of
um disobey what their teachers are
saying
um I I've come from a school this
afternoon where I'm speaking to the
deputy head teacher who was saying that
they he literally had a child standing
there being verbally abusive and
circling around the teachers like going
what you're going to do about it then
and when contacting the parents the
parents were we hasn't done anything
wrong so
when you're faced with things like that
it becomes very difficult to try and
support and
and
um
get into these children and get them to
listen to us because they they don't see
Authority as something to be concerned
about
so there's a couple of things that I've
suggested there's a couple of things
I've put out there to the schools that I
would like to to do one of those being
take knife arches into the schools I'd
like to take knife arches into all of
the schools I would like all of them to
sign up for it and the reason that I
want all of them to sign up for is
because then they can't sit there and
say oh we're being picked on and we look
like we're a bad school when we're not
um one of the other things I would like
for the schools to give us an open door
policy so that my officers can go in at
any time of the day and just go and walk
around the school talk to Children I've
got a school where I've got an open
invite my officers can go in at any time
they're allowed to go into lessons and
interrupt the lessons for five minutes
and say hello speak to the children
speak to the teachers and
um due to some other problems with
another school they've also kind of said
yep please come in and I spent two hours
walking around the school going into
lessons and actually speaking to the
students in the lessons and supporting
the teachers when the kids were walking
past going from one lesson to another
and they're being told to pull their
trousers up Tuck their shirts in and
they're just walking off and ignoring
the teachers myself and some of the
offices that I was with were assisting
the teachers and pulling the kids to one
side and and making them do what they've
been told to do pretty much
if we can get the schools down and up to
that brilliant because then my offices
can go in and they can speak to the
teachers they can support the teachers
they can show that the teachers aren't
on their own that they're not trying to
stand up to these kids and with no
support from outside
um
we've we've got currently uh in
Chelmsford at the moment at one of the
Schools project that is that's been
um ongoing for the last few months
called players one which is
basically a 10-week course where an
officer is assigned to the school
they'll go in and the school will
identify some children within a certain
year group that
um
are vulnerable for various different
reasons they're disruptive in lessons
they're I don't know missing school
they're not attending classes they're on
the verge of being expelled whatever the
case may be and we're trying to work
with those children and pull them back
from going down the wrong path and bring
them back into into sort of
engaging with us and engaging with the
teachers and this is something that has
been trialled it's been trialled that
we've had three we're on the third
session and we're trialing it there's
spit outside speakers agencies coming in
and explaining to the children about
drugs alcohol
CSE risk
we have
um perception which is a very big thing
so we'll show them some CCTV footage of
a big group of youths with the hoods up
standing outside McDonald's or standing
in the High Street and what does that
perception look like because they might
not be up to any good they might be
absolutely fine and doing nothing but
the perception is that they are naughty
horrible
people to be afraid of and that's
something that we want to teach them to
be aware of
I think it's really important that we
get into the schools and we try and
teach this to the children that we've
identified are vulnerable as being
pulled into this type of
way of life
um we need the schools to sign up to
this we need the schools to agree to
doing it and once they're on board
obviously we can't run a session across
all the schools at the same time but we
can certainly look at the schools that
are asking if we've got children within
that school that are sitting with our
child and young person officer or
they've come to light with us many a
time or we've got reports from the
school that they're struggling and they
need assistance then we can
almost Matrix score them and we can
identify which schools we need to go
into first and which schools we need to
go and help
um you know there's been a success our
first 10 weeks was a success we had one
child from the group of 14 children
stepped forward and saying that after
the 10 weeks he stepped forward and said
that he was being used as a runner to
run drugs and he hadn't had the ability
to be able to stand up and talk about it
beforehand so it was successful
and those children that have just done
the last two groups speaking to the Head
teacher or the deputy head today he said
that they've got all of those children
all 14 of those are now off of report
they're all engaging they're all talking
to the teachers and you know it's and
it's so it's been really positive so
when we get into the first mesh meeting
I'm not sure when it's going to be that
will be put out to the school so that'll
be put out to all of the schools so
it'll be put out to the schools in the
Malden District
Sergeant dolby's team will pick that up
and their his team will go into those
schools and we will offer that play as
one to the schools the idea being after
the half an hour or so 45 minutes of the
input from the external agency they then
get to go and play football either with
a Chelmsford City football player
um we're looking at trying to get uh
billericky football Academy college
students on board to try and see if we
can get them to come in and engage with
the children as well
and also
um
uh active Essex are on board and they
want to be part of it as well so there's
a few details that we need to iron out
and it is something that is still very
much in its infancy but as of next year
we're hoping to get that rolled out
across the board because I do believe
strongly believe that we need to get
into them as young as we can to try and
change that cycle of events so that when
they get older
that you know sometimes it's a little
bit late to try and turn somebody around
when they've already gone down the wrong
path it's a lot more difficult to get
them to come back onto the right way of
behaving so there is a lot of work on
going with the schools but it's very
very slow it's not something that's
going to happen overnight but it is
there the groundwork is there
anybody else before I go
if I can remember some of the things I'm
trying to talk about sorry I'm gonna
have to get myself a notepad
I honestly think you're on a hide into
nothing with the schools and the reason
I say that is probably because a lot of
the problems stem from the lack of
parental control
I mean don't get me on the audience
because it's basically there's no
discipline in the house
and it's probably because the parents
are on Drake or they're on drugs which
is happening a lot now and they're
basically getting out and they think
that's the norm which is why they end up
doing whatever but I mean you're
interacting with these with these
children but if you've got a child
that's
basically disrupting the whole class
they're not allowed to touch them
anymore
you know and I went I can do whatever I
want what can you do about it
oh no it it was the strap or whatever
like you know and have some of that
but you can't do it it's a nambi pambi
state now and because there's no
discipline it's why they think they can
get away with it
I'm not on a positive okay
um I'm not sure if it's the police and
crime commissioner puts out a a circle
or something I tend to get that at least
once a week but I think is it a local
one where you guys the rural team or
something like you said about the woods
is that the rural team putting that out
because that's really informative and it
lets people know where they've been and
what they've done that's the dispatch
it's a really good idea yeah
yeah that's produced by a department and
they get set up
have you thought about getting some
psychics that might sort these figures
that would help out counselor
anybody else want to ask a question
before I go to counselor hurt
that's the hurt thank you very much um
really just to say that um as always
it's always nice to see the police and
crime commissioner come to these
meetings I have the opportunity to speak
to him but I know that other committee
members do not
um I think that the point raised by
Council Morgan about the new housing is
quite right you know let's have him here
and let's see if he can justify the
amount of police per head of population
I would like to
have this committee talk to him about
the crime figures
the second so that is that is my request
that this committee asks the police and
crime commissioner to to come here in at
the March meeting uh to my knowledge I
think he's been here twice in my 10
years
so I think I would like to see him here
uh the second answer that the last time
I asked him to come he would come to
speak to us but not be interrogated by
the committee because he's already has
his own interrogation by you and
everybody else
so you'll come and do a presentation to
council but he might not do a
presentation this is this I know it's I
mean respect chairman this is this is a
scrutiny committee yeah it's not it's
not a nice little comfortable no I know
that uh chat
um and I I think that uh I think that we
should make the invitation
um if other members agree with that
um the other thing that that I would
like to know is and I I have spoken
about this before is the knife bin
that's outside this
uh kept these Council offices it's been
there for about four years as far as I
know there's no planning permission for
it but it does seem to be part of the
furniture now I've asked for it to be
moved to the long fields and uh perhaps
because I I don't think that it should
stay in one place all all at one time I
know that 16 tons of weapons were
recovered from all of the bins in Essex
and I did ask if we could have details
of what was taken from the Malden bin
because if it's empty then we need to
move it
um if it's if it's full then we perhaps
we need to concentrate more on the knife
on knife knife crime so is there uh
dispenser you might be able to help me
Mr Clark with this about the figures for
for our knife bin I appreciate that the
the cause has been lost to move it
because there's no funding for it but I
would like to see it moved all the same
thank you chairman thank you
very much
on that one are you happy for me to
respond you've made by all means so as
councilor Herald now I've been
championing his cause for the the knife
Ben so um
when it was last emptied it was almost
full
so knives were being put in there I
don't know who buy but it was almost
full because I took a picture of my
mobile phone because I was very
surprised
um with regards to
moving the bin
um
I
had an email on Monday in relation to
this because uh I'd asked at the last
response to authorities group meeting
we discussed I moving the bin but B
in our opinion we thought the bin was a
little bit too big
I massive so um we uh I contacted the
um Chief Inspector who's dealing with it
and I've got the image here which I'll
show you after the meeting they've now
designed a smaller bin
which fits
conveniently spits that fits a wheelie
bin inside which I makes it easier for
emptying because it can just go in into
that
um as of Monday I have negotiated a
decent price
for the new set bin
um so uh
presently we're gonna go 50 50 with the
balance and vulnerability unit for a new
smaller bin
and
it's the intention is if you want to go
and see one of these new Bins there's
one in Loudon
um is that it will be installed in
January
so when when the next programmed
emptying of the bins is which is January
they'll remove the one from the front of
the Civic offices and subject to us
getting a concrete hard standing by the
Longfield it will be installed there
so I I know it's been a long time that
I'm finally getting there for you
Council ahead thank you very much and
well done well done so my proposal then
chairman is that we invite the police
and crime commissioner to our March
meeting if the committee agree
all in favor
all in favor Tara
yes
being a fossil I've just remembered
something else
basically I'm a little bit worried as
councilor spencely said
that we've that we've net well not we
they have decided that heybridge Parish
Council to to get rid of the local
team
um I'm wondering where or if there is a
contact number within MDC well we're not
using their service are we so I'm
wondering who who we could report any
intel to before it used to be to the
community team
now you're supposed to
do it online to MDC for someone that
might have a look at the information
over possibly two or three days because
that's the only time she's in and then
after something that's happening she'll
then detail it but that's not going to
happen now because they're not in that
system
so that's going to be a major issue and
just one other thing is I did actually
attend the silver Monday thing
I mean I can only stay two and a half
hours because I go and sort my brother
out but um yeah it was really good event
I spoke to I think the name was Rosie
and there was PC Rosie I never see Jim
there but there you go uh but yeah I
mean you know he gave her a lot of Intel
because I said I'm really against the
drugs and I mean in my in my Road in
particular
there is a major drug issue
um and also I'm glad to hear that there
was a drug raid in Salisbury because I
know where that's being dealt with as
well but
what am I now eh
but thanks for all that you are trying
to do
I've got one two questions uh with the
massive increasing houses in the
district
and the massive increasing people
does the percentage of crime and all
that relate back to the percentage
increase in the number of people that
moved into the area and does it make it
look better or worse
because that might help your figures
you've got an increase but you've had an
increase in population as well
I don't know okay right next one is
going back in history we had a local
Bobby used to grab you by the luggles
and take it to your parents tell you off
in the school we got the cane and
discipline was good in the whole
District nobody got away with anything
and crime was sorted out so he went
round in his little Villa set to all the
farms and the Dustin Estates
I need you everybody no I'm not watching
no I'm not watching heartbeat but have
we gone backwards in time really by
being so modern
you sit sit in the house and you hear
these police cars go past every night
and the criminals can hear them coming
so they're gone before they get there
I'll leave it with that I think
there there are some crimes that are
committed that we request the response
officers not to have their blues and
that they do a silent approach good so
there will be particular crimes such as
Suspects on premises where we will say
can you please do a silent approach
so
there are times where the blues and twos
need so that the victims can also hear
that the help is on the way yeah that's
fair enough because I live in Lexington
just off the High Street
and all you hear is every day and night
baby
and of course when the roads are blocked
how do you get there because you've got
no police houses in the district don't
anymore
uh I don't believe no no no okay I'll
leave it at that
but yeah I I feel that we shouldn't we
shouldn't leave this meeting unless we
unless we speak about Crime Stoppers of
course oh 800 treble five treble one
it's a free phone number that anybody
can use anybody can phone and that will
get information back to the police and I
do hope I know that Spencer promotes it
I do hope that the police promote it as
well we should be having cards they
should be given out
um and I think that that would be a very
good thing if that is happening at the
moment but I think that I just want to
bring it to the tension of members and
any other members of the public who
might be listening to this oh 800 treble
five treble one
do I need to put it on television
anymore do we yeah you got it on YouTube
anyway thank you you three very much for
your presentation it's been very
interesting and very informative
and thank you very much
yeah I'm a crime stopper for Essex yeah
so um yeah and he knows that yeah so
yeah
we do use um
right any other license of business that
the chairman decides are Urgent it's
just to call the crime permission of
this meeting yes
and that's it no other things you want
to investigate by the police to come to
the next crime
well I'd like to see the figures reduce
okay right
we'll try our best
right I closed the meeting at
9 33.